one of the most important ways to use
your Y is to use it to help you find a
job that you love I mean that's one of
the reasons we put this whole course
together to help people find a job or a
career that brings them joy and
fulfillment but the question is
practically speaking how does one go
about actually doing that well it comes
from research
I mean answering a 1 tad certainly won't
tell you much unless the company is
particularly good at articulating their
why which some companies are but most or
not simply answering a 1 tad and saying
I'm very qualified to do this job really
is not finding a company that speaks to
your wife
a good place to start is who the
companies that you already like the
companies you already love the ones that
you already have intense loyalty to the
odds are that they all have something in
common they say something about who you
are so that's a good place to start what
are the organizations like them Peck and
you can go work for those even better
but to do your research to find out the
history of these companies spend time I
mean this is gonna be many many many
many years of your life you can spend
more time there than you will at home
it's worth taking a few hours to
research where these organizations come
from who their founders work read quotes
read books written by their founders and
understand where the where the the birth
of the company and where it came from
and this will either inspire you or not
you want to be inspired by the original
cause around which the company was
founded not necessarily the current
statements by the current CEO those
don't necessarily help you and if you
find something that really sparks to you
those are the exact same words you want
to use when you apply for the job when
you sit down or send the email and say
oh the reason I'm applying for this job
is because I looked into your history
and I saw and I read the words of Sam
Walton all right read the words of
whoever the founder is of Henry Ford and
what he believed and the way he
approached the problem and what he and
how he wanted to serve people it spoke
to me on a level that I'm not used to
and I may or may not be a perfectly
qualified for the job you have but I can
tell you I am so excited and driven and
so want to be a part of what you're
doing so that this thing that the
founder began lasts forever now if
there's someone who's not interested in
that that kind of
to come work for them on a level where
you're viscerally engaged with the
company then you really didn't wouldn't
want to work there anyway because they
will not reward the right things so
really do your research and just simply
be honest talk about the things that
actually speak to you that actually
excited you when you first read about
the history and the words of the
founding of the company